the House Judiciary Committee's expected
incoming Democratic Chairman claims
president Trump appointed a new acting
Attorney General to quote sabotage a
Russian investigation protesters rallied
around the country yesterday calling for
protection of the special council's
probe after the sudden removal of
Attorney General Jeff Sessions major
Garrett is at the White House with more
on this story major de sessions
departure do you think what do you think
it means for the Muller investigation
well for right now it means the acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker is for
the time being the sole Justice
Department official overseeing Special
Counsel Robert Muller's Russia
investigation and Whitaker is a public
critic of that underlying investigation
but it's a question how long Whitaker
will stay he has no Senate confirmation
and there are many constitutional
scholars who questioned his legal
legitimacy is acting Attorney General
but for as long as he's in that post any
charges Muller wants to bring in the
future must be cleared by Whitaker and
at such time that Muller finishes his
full report he has to run it by Whitaker
and Whitaker would decide if there are
any implications in that report of
presidential wrongdoing of a criminal
kind whether to send that to Congress
now Democrats for many reasons want
Whitaker to recuse himself or be
replaced by someone with Senate
confirmation they sent a letter to rod
Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney General
who by the way has been Senate confirmed
that he should continue that his say
Rosenstein supervised Muller's ongoing
Russia investigation now possibly an
attempt to calm the waters the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell said he
believes Muller will be allowed to
continue his work unobstructed Lindsey
Graham Republican senator from South
Carolina told reporters there's nothing
to worry about
as far as a future permanent attorney
general nominee Graham said the trey
gowdy the outgoing South Carolina
Republican congressman is in the mix so
is Rudy Guiliani outgoing Florida
Attorney General Pam Bondi and chris
Christie who was here at the White House
yesterday all of that will be determined
in the near future
Norah major thank you interesting to
hear Kellyanne Conway's husband writing
an op-ed saying that this appointment is
unconstitutional it's illegal and that
whatever he tries to do in that position
is invalid pretty strong words I would
like to know the conversation that goes
on at their dinner table because they
are such up
it's on many issues actually since
Kelly's been publicly defending they're
not actually he didn't want me